Now we can check out one of Scott's
repositories to get a sense of his work.
Let's check out NGFX over here the most
popular repository he's worked on.
We can see here that Scott
made the most recent commit.
If we click through to the contributors.
It's clear that Scott has
written most of the code.
Going back to their repository, firstly
we see a short description of the code.
This is a library for
making animations with Angular.
He's also included a link to
a get hub page for the library.
These GitHub pages are easy to
create and very impressive.
Here's the readme, one of the most
important parts of repository.
Its main purpose is to help others
understand and use the code.
A repository without a readme
has no starting point for
someone to understand.
It will come back to the read me
it deserves special attention.
Now we can scroll back up to look at
the most recent commits Scott has made.
Most of the recent commits are updating
the version number and other chores.
But there are some features and
other additions too.
We could look through some of these
commits to understand how Scott
writes code.
But I'm not going to get into that now.
Next we'll hear from a hiring manager
at Udacity about what he looks for
in a good high profile.